et il ya beaucoup de femmes qui sont
ramenés à ça comme karine le marchand
qui a eu la meilleure des réponses fin
août car il a publié une photo de ses
longues jambes sur un stade en train de
bronzer regarder et un relou qui a
commenté les vergers tueur c'est moche
et karine le marchand a répondu elle a
dit merci à vous pour cette remarque
élégante et constructive
je ne manquerai pas de vous envoyer des
photos de ma cellulite et d'un herpès
labial près de monter un cabinet de
coaching faire votre empathie votre
gentillesse positive ferait merveille
bonne journée à vous l'a bien fait elle
a répondu d'abord il ya également oui
sophie davant si ça lui est arrivé fin
août à la poster une photo elle est en
mini short noir avec un beau sourire
c'est pas c'est pas celle là mais bon en
tout cas oui on peut voir là voilà où
elle montrait ses bras et ses jambes
mais il ya quand même une internaute
assez désobligeant de camille ouais
c'est moche vos bras et vos jambes mais
c'est quand même terrible qu'on ramène
toujours les femmes à leur âge à leur
physique
enfin c'est incroyable cette affaire
vous quand vous postez des trucs qu'on
dit pas au top après impôts de ventre tu
as des gens alors c'est pas vrai ira le
cas on aurait vraiment non mais vraiment
les femmes ça me gêne beaucoup plus je
suis désolé oui mais les hommes on s'en
fout tour il les a mal aimée dont son
foudre vous avez raison enfin moi je
m'en fous - en conjuguant au physique
mais en tout cas les femmes à chaque
fois je veux dire total sont très belles
wyatt est bonne quand elles sont un peu
plus âgés on va dire oh là là tes
vieilles enfin c'est vrai c'est
insupportable et louane je veux dire
c'est pas la première à ceux à se faire
attaquer trois gros ce faux billets eux
héloïse martin alors il ya eu lieu mais
louise morte à la poste mais s'est fait
fracasser
elle a participé à fort boyard c'est
allah dit c'est dingue de recevoir
autant d' insulte sur mon physique j'ai
participé à fort boyard
nous avons joué pour une magnifique
association je n'étais pas là pour faire
la belle
et pour me surpasser pour essayer de
réussir des épreuves très difficiles
elle a même décidé de quitter les
réseaux sociaux à cause de ça héloïse
martin c'est vrai qu'elle s'est fait
fracasser sur twitter et est-ce que
voilà il ya ce que vous avez déjà été
victime vous voilà de photos drogba
leyrit kelly o'kelly mois tous les ter
ah ouais tous les jours
quoi pourquoi bas alerte google qui élit
vdev y est elle enceinte mais c'est
aussi les médias c'est pas seulement les
gens en quoi il met des photos
oui ils reprennent pas parce que c'est
moi qui ma fille ne pouvait assumer mais
c'est pas ça qui va m'arrêter mais oui
j'avoue
ça a été lourd ouais c'est pas c'est pas
que ça me blesse spécialement parce que
sinon j'arrêterai de poster justement
moi je préfère en rigoler en rajouter et
justement dire bah ouais bah giscard là
et je vous emmerde primaire et ce bien
que manifestement qui agace vous avez
déjà eu vous d ouais bien sûr mais de
toute façon à chaque passage télé je
pensais à chaque photo c'est des trucs
genre ah on mange bien la cantine ou moi
on a un peu grossi sans arrêt sur le
poids sans arrêt sur la coiffure il
trouve toujours un angle pour attaquer
mais après ça reste
mine de rien des commentaires
minoritaires d'accord c'est sûr